le vice président du front national est
l'invité de preuves par 3 bonsoir
florian philippot et merci d'être avec
nous vous répondrez à trois grandes
questions au cours de cette émission de
public sénat avec l' agence
france-presse
dailymotion première question syrie est
ce que vous vous ranger derrière
vladimir poutine et bachar el-assad pour
combattre le groupe etat islamique
deuxième question que vous posera dans
un quart d'heure guillaume daudin de l'
agence france-presse
le programme du fn est-il suicidaire et
oui c'est ce qu'affirment les sénateurs
les républicains qui ont décidé de
contre attaquer sur ce terrain là sur le
terrain économique enfin troisième
question avec perrine tarneaud de public
sénat au sujet des élections régionales
vos ambitions sont elles des mesures et
oui vous misez vous l'avez dit vous-même
sur quatre à cinq régions même cinq à
six régions gagnables
or pour l'instant les sondages ne vous
en donne qu'une florian philippot mais
on parle d'abord de la syrie
la syrie vous vous définissez à longueur
d'interviews comme patriote on n'avait
que le mot la france à la bouche n'est
ce pas et pourtant la france aujourd'hui
on le voit est engagé dans la coalition
internationale contre contre les
djihadistes du groupe etat islamique et
ça n'est donc pas paradoxal pour vous de
vous ranger derrière d'autres chefs de
guerre que sont aujourd'hui vladimir
poutine et bachar el-assad
mais je n'ai que ce soit en matière
étrangères ou en matière intérieur je
souhaite que la france soit libre que
les choses soient claires faire une
coalition participer à la coalition
internationale ne peut se concevoir
quelle que soit la configuration de
cette coalition que si la france
maîtrisent ces opérations sa décision
d'action ou de dynaction et les
motivations stratégique et jeu c'est
pour ça que nous sommes favorables par
exemple à ce que la france quitte le
commandement intégré de l'otan dans
lequel nicolas sarkozy nous avait remis
de manière forte influence quand il
était président éditions et qu'elle
existe la france y participe
oui mais la france y participe très bien
il faut lutter contre l' état islamique
oui ça c'est l'urgence des urgences
c'est une barbarie épouvantable c'est un
risque pour notre propre sécurité
nationale on le sait bien et c'est un
cancer pour toute la région moyen-orient
comme corne de l'afrique
maintenant il faut le faire de manière
efficace et intelligente et on le fait
de manière efficace et intelligente si
on coopère avec l'en
des acteurs qui sur le terrain
connaissent la situation et lutte déjà
contre des shu l'état islamique
je pense notamment bien sûr au
gouvernement syrien moi quand j'entends
de la merkel nous expliquait il ya
quelques jours qu'il faut discuter avec
le gouvernement syrien et monsieur el
assad je ne peux que me réjouir non pas
que je porte dans mon coeur dans mon
coeur
bachar el-assad mais simplement c'est le
bon sens qui prévaut c'est ce qu'on
appelle la politique du moins leur mal
alors si on est inefficace et est
nouveau je le dis clairement avec la
sécurité des français
barack obama a parlé lui du tyran bachar
al assad est ce que le mot est juste
pour vous tout simplement le tyran on
peut être qu'à un grand malheur à ce
moment là disons le aussi pour le havre
1-2 le roi d'arabie saoudite l'émir du
qatar elle a géré si on a une vision pas
il ne jette pas des barils de prod2 de
produits chimiques sur leur population
enfin vous savez que sur les attaques
chimiques je suis pas inspecteurs de
l'onu
mais vous avez plusieurs versions dont
certaines qui vous explique que ce sont
les rebelles islamistes et qui ont
utilisé ces armes chimiques et nous
avons c'est vrai en syrie nous avons une
guerre civile c'est vrai il ya des morts
c'est horrible qui est une guerre civile
mais notre politique diplomatique et
militaire n'est pas étrangère à cette
guerre civile on a mis de l'huile sur le
feu quand on a armé et financé les
fameux rebelles 1 face à bachar el-assad
fait que parmi ces rebelles il y avait
des masses de plus en plus conséquente
d'islamistes de djihadistes extrêmement
dangereux on a mis de l'huile sur le feu
on a contribué à dégrader la situation à
alimenter cette guerre civile meurtrière
donc je trouve qu'on est parfaitement
mal placé quand on s'appelle monsieur
obama ou monsieur fabius ou monsieur
hollande monsieur sarkozy de donner des
leçons parce que on est l'un des
responsables les leçons et également
principe si on écoute encore barack
obama
effectivement vous le citez il a
poursuivi à l'onu est-ce qu'on peut
suivre une logique qui consiste donc à
soutenir un tyran parce que
l'alternative serait pire vous vous
défendez cette logique mais moi je dis
attendez soit on applique une vision
morale des relations internationales
dont le fait partout parce que la morale
n'est pas relative
c'est un principe même en philosophie de
la mort à l'aller absolue où elle
n'existe pas donc on le fait aussi
eh bien on arabie saoudite ce pas
formidable régime ça vous dirait quand
vous dites ce régime qui décale invitons
concis fille on va vous rétorquer que
non on parle d'une guerre civile qui a
fait plus de 240 milles
une majorité imputables à ce que le roi
tirant une roi d'arabie saoudite se
place pas mal lui non plus en matière de
non-respect des droits de l'homme devra
de la femme et de non respect de la
démocratie c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire même même chose au qatar et à ce
moment là on est là aussi était inquiète
pour les droits de l'homme vous savez
est épinglée on n'en est pas encore au
niveau de la cuisse à outils des regards
c'est vrai merci on en est même très
loin mais donc on applique ce principe
de morale à tout le monde
ou alors on même on peut refuser de
discuter que certains gouvernements que
le gouvernement chinois parce que les
droits de l'homme s'est pas non plus
terrible bon soit on est face à la
réelle politique et face à elle un souci
d'efficacité et de sécurité
on doit le gagner contre cette barbarie
quel état islamique et donc on le fait
intelligemment et on le fait évidemment
avec la russie évidemment que le
gouvernement syrien et on redonne
quelques moyens à nos armes et des
moyens humains et matériels
parce qu'on a saccagé l'armée française
depuis tant d'années sous sarkozy depuis
soulondre vous avez souligné
l'inefficacité des frappes aériennes de
la coalition est ce que pour vous faire
infiniment diva qu'elles sont
inefficaces je dis qu'il faut les faire
moi je suis favorable à cabrières
présent ils n'ont pas suffi à faire
reculer les djihadistes oui elle vient
le fort tard elles ne sont pas à leur
optimum d'efficacité parce qu'elles ne
sont pas faites en partenariat avec ceux
qui connaissent le tir assez pour vous
est ce que pour vous poutine est l'homme
qui va nous libérer des djihadistes de
la menace du groupe etat islamique oui
ou non il peut être l'un des acteurs
moi j'ai jamais vu personne comme un
libérateur ou un héros absolu c'est l'un
des acteurs majeurs évidemment de ce
dossier parce qu'il lutte contre l' état
islamique
il a intérêt à lutter contre cet état
islamique c'est pour ça qu'il le fait il
est en étant leur argument est une
grande puissance de la région et en même
temps laurent fabius a critiqué lors de
son discours à une conférence de presse
à l'onu
il a dit il ya ceux qui parlent beaucoup
et qui en fait n'ont pas engagé pour
l'instant un seul avion contre les
djihadistes il parlait des russes en
l'occurrence n'est pas ça n'est pas le
cas et ce n'est plus vrai et surtout
monsieur fabius est dans une logique
permanente de recherche du conflit ils
recherchent ils provoquent par des
formules qui ne sont pas digne d'un
ministre des affaires étrangères quand
il dit il avait dit il ya deux ans je
crois monsieur bachar al assad ne
mériterait pas d'être sur terre on parle
pas comme cela quand on est ministre des
affaires étrangères d'un chef de l'état
reconnu puis dire qu'on l'ait nous qu'on
l'ait pas il est quand même légitime
légal
et reconnu par la communauté
internationale on ne parle pas ainsi
deux partenaires vers la france siège au
conseil de sécurité de l'onu comme
membre permanent à côté de la russie
donc on ne parle pas comme ça de ses
partenaires on essaie d'être efficace on
doit viser la sécurité internationale et
la sécurité des français on va pas viser
autre chose
alors si on est vraiment dans cet
objectif là et qu'on n'est pas dans
l'idéologie ou le l'aplaventrisme devant
les états unis parce que c'est ça le
gros problème des fab us et des autres
c'est qu'ils sont complètement dans la
ventre alors on va écouter avec les
ats-unis parle alors on lutte réellement
efficacement contre l'état et cela alors
on n'a rien d'autre à faire aujourd'hui
que de lutter contre l etat islamique
on va écouter justement françois
hollande qui reste inflexible par
rapport à ce que vous dites en l'écho
depuis d'ailleurs de la réaction du
président russe et vous nous direz quel
sur les mots vous préférez c'est l'armée
de bachar al assad qui combat le
terrorisme en face à face
il faut que nous reconnaissions que
personne d'autre à part bachar al-assad
et son armée lutte réellement contre le
terrorisme j'en vois qui déploient tous
leurs efforts diplomatiques pour
incorporer bachar al assad dans ce
processus
mais on ne peut pas faire travailler
ensemble les victime et le bourreau
assad est à l'origine du problème
il ne peut pas faire partie de la
solution alors encore une question de
logique l'a fait jean philippe os que
françois hollande se trompe quand il
affirme donc que bachar al assad ne fait
pas partie de la solution mais il veut
travailler qui françois hollande avec
les rebelles islamistes avec les
djihadistes avec al qaïda al nostra
c'est avec cela que françois hollande
veut travailler papa moi moi je veux pas
travailler avec les djihadistes pat
riley qu'al-qaïda je veux travailler
avec ceux qui luttent contre l'état
islamique et qui jusqu'ici au moins eu
ce mérite
1 ils ont des défauts mais ils ont au
moins eu le mérite de protéger les
minorités qui sont massacrés par les
talibans dont le chef de l'état rate une
opportunité c'est une chance mais il a
même trois quatre trains de retard parce
qu'eux-mêmes
même angela merkel 1 normalement des
camps merkel siffle quelque chose
françois hollande rapplique et la mana
illa il avait déjà dit qu'on pouvait
plus il oeuvra dans quelques jours
probablement qui s'alignera comme il le
fait traditionnellement là ce sera
heureux pour une fois mais mais mais
même sur angela merkel il a du retard
elle elle a évolué
elle a compris qu'on ne pouvait pas
faire autrement que de discuter avec le
gouvernement syrien
voilà mais dans le même temps il serait
bien comme chef des armées je le dis de
renforcer le budget des armées
françaises ça c'est une vraie vraie
priorité parce que sinon on parle dans
le vide
si nous n'avons pas d'armée ou pas
d'armé digne de ce nom en termes
d'hommes et d'effectifs et de moyens
alors on parle dans le vide alors est ce
que vous imaginez les réfugiés syriens
qui arrive aujourd'hui en europe et qui
ont fuit d'ailleurs pour la plupart les
bombes syrienne retourner un jour dans
leur pays
si bachar el-assad restent sur place
déjà vous vous dites réfugiés moi je dis
qu'il n'ya pas que des réfugiés
elle avait la queue des syrahs questions
posées a pas que des syriens dans la
sphère des migrants dont on parle
beaucoup il y a les migrants qui
viennent de la corne de l'afrique qui
viennent du moyen-orient certains
d'ailleurs se prétendent syriens sans
l'être on le sait bon et il ya aussi des
syriens non mais là on parle de mai il y
a les réfugiés il y a beaucoup dit de
l'europe ouvre ses frontières ya
beaucoup de syriens il
il ya beaucoup de syriens qui quittent
les kits la syrie du fait des exactions
et de la barbarie de l'état islamique et
et ces gens là je veux dire ne ne fuit
pas bachar el-assad bon qu'on soit
prudent sur cette affaire de migrants
parce que d'abord ils ne sont pas tous
réfugiés
ensuite nous n'avons absolument pas les
moyens notamment en france pays qui
connaît six millions de chômeurs 10
millions de pauvres d'accueillir des
centaines de milliers de personnes
supplémentaires qui s'ajouteront ne faut
pas l'oublier à l'immigration qu'il
existe déjà depuis des années des années
deux cent mille entrées légales par an +
l'asile qui existe déjà plus
l'immigration clandestine massive qui
existe déjà
nous n'avons pas les moyens de les
accueillir moi je demande plutôt qu'on
fasse pression sur les pays riverains
notamment les pétromonarchies du golfe
qui n'ont pas accueilli ou quasiment pas
jusqu'ici je pense au qatar je pense à
l'arabie saoudite ou à quelques autres
et bien d'en accueillir parce que eux
s'ils sont ils sont écoutés peu ils sont
très riches et peut-être que
culturellement ils auront plus de
facilité à les intégrer et il faut des
quotas mondiaux de répartition des
réfugiés comme s'apprête à le demander
l'homme fort de angry viktor orban
ajoutant encore à la tribune de l'onu
non je ne suis pas favorable aux tables
mondiaux parce que par définition je ne
suis pas favorable à ce qu'il y ait un
gouvernement mondial qui surpasse les
gouvernements des nations et les
démocraties nationales je pense que
c'est à chaque nation de définir sa
politique d'immigration ce que nous
plus faire aujourd'hui du fait des
règles de l'union européenne du fait de
l'ouverture du mondial mais vous voulez
en imposer dans les pays arabes
qu'on fasse pression qu'on fasse
pression sur ces pays voisins ça évitera
d'ailleurs à ces migrants de faire la
traversée de la méditerranée au risque
de leur vie
ban ki moon ce qu'on sait qu'à quand
même des milliers de morts chaque année
en méditerranée aix étaient plusieurs
milliers le secrétaire régional de l'onu
ban ki moon a appelé l'europe à faire
plus pour les réfugiés il explique que
notre comportement doit être guidée par
les lois internationales des droits de
l'homme et la compassion oui d'accord la
compassion très bien mais enfin c'est
vrai dans les rapports de l'onu comme
des comme dans les rapports d'ailleurs
du grand patronat s'est amusé en ce sens
on lit la même chose on nous explique
depuis des années et même des décennies
que l'europe doit accueillir des
dizaines de millions d'immigrés qu'elle
doit en accueillir
je ne sais combien d'ici 2050 bon tout
cela n'est pas raisonnable
nous sommes aujourd'hui confrontés à
tant de problèmes économiques sociaux
tant de problèmes liés à l'immigration
massive déjà je pense au communautarisme
je pense aux problèmes d'assimilation
qui ne se fait plus ou plus correctement
qu'on ne peut pas se permettre d'avoir
ce genre de discours complètement
déconnecté 2,6 et ans claude juncker
mais oui elle sourit j'ai les discours
d'extrême droite dans les syndicats mais
applaudie par les syndicats européens
oui à il a cité d'extra bottes qui en
appelle à des sentiments indigne selon
lui oui mais randy jean bienvenu les
réfugiés monsieur juncker ferait bien de
plutôt de se préoccuper de lutter contre
les paradis fiscaux notamment celui
qu'il a dirigé pendant des années au
luxembourg
je crois d'ailleurs qu'il va être
rattrapé par une affaire sur ce sujet là
si j'ai bien suivi et vous n'aurez choix
qui sera préoccupé par d'autres
problèmes hydrauliques à rendre certains
économistes et c'est dans ma poche
pierre moscovici qui dit que les
réfugiés sont ne sont pas du tout un
fardeau nouvelles menaces mais c'est
normal qu'elle a accueilli sur la
croissance mais que la commission
européenne vous explique qu'il faut plus
d'immigration c'est dans son adn
l'union européenne est immigrationniste
dans son adn
elle veut l'ouverture totale des
frontières elle veut casser les nations
elle veut plus d'immigration elle veut
dissoudre les identité nationale est
dissoute les modèles sociaux pays ne
font pas assez d'enfants tout simplement
on pense à l'allemagne devrait plutôt
misé sur une politique familiale
je suis heureux qu en france il subsiste
encore à peu près une politique
familiale et nathalie ce même si elle
est plus faible qu'avant et que c'est
regrettable mais
que le grand patronat que son bras renée
politique c'est à dire la commission
européenne demande plus d'immigration
saine écologique san écologique mais
nous ne voulons pas dans cet état
d'esprit encore à un mot sur ce qui
s'est passé ce qui se passe d'ailleurs
encore à l'onu il ya eu cette joute on
l'a vu entre barack obama et vladimir
poutine vous avez choisi votre camp
j'ai choisi le camp de la france - a je
suis pas rallié à l'est ou à l'ouest
pensent que c'est une vision de guerre
froide quand vous avez l'air y est morte
depuis au moins 25 m a quand même l'air
satisfait de voir que finalement c'est
vrai dire
poutine qui a tenu la vedette lors de
l'assemblée générale mais nenad moi je
suis pour un meilleur équilibre et je
suis pour un bon équilibre et celle qu
on le diabolise ni les élus ni ni la
russie je constate simplement que depuis
des années et des années sous l'ump
comme sous le ps notre politique
étrangère a complètement soumis aux
états unis ce n'est pas ça la france
normalement que la france ait une voix
libre que la france ait une diplomatie
indépendante dans le concert des nations
bien évidemment alors si on peut
rééquilibrer les choses je m'en réjouis
livrés dans les discours également parce
que les discours et dans les impasses
que par exemple valu une des meilleures
poutines a souri quand il a fustigé la
volonté des occidentaux des états unis
notamment de valoriser le modèle de la
démocratie qu'est le nôtre sur la
planète
oui mais ça n'a strictement rien à voir
sur nous défendons-nous nos valeurs
démocratiques et nous émeut et
j'aimerais qu'on les défende d'ailleurs
bien mieux parce qu'avant de donner des
leçons à la terre entière matière de
démocratie et de droits de l'homme
on ferait bien de les appliquer je crois
que dans les classements de liberté de
la presse
on est très mal classés au niveau
international se croient que par rapport
aux puissances privées et publiques et
politiques
je crois que la démocratie française est
malade quand parce qu'elle n'est plus
représentative parce que les modes
d'élection font que les assemblées ne
sont pas représentatifs du peuple
il manque de la proportionnelle et nous
nous réclamons la proportionnelle et
puis il ya plus de référendum en france
ils sont où les référendums sa valeur
nous en avait 10 ans qui a pas eu un
référendum national que vous en
prométhéen si man plusieurs même
plusieurs encore un premier dans les six
mois si marine le pen est élue il
portera sur l'euro c'est bien cela
l'union européenne sur lui n'y aura pas
référence à l'union belle comme au
royaume-uni absolument alors donc ça
nous amène tout est la deuxième partie
de preuve par trois avec cette deuxième
question que vous posera guillaume
daudin de la fp le programme du fn
est-il suicidaire rien
oui suicidaire cataclysmique même si
kelly petit il a cassé ce que disent les
sénateurs les républicains qui ont
choisi de riposter sur le terrain
économique
ils ont vu que le terrain de la morale
la force à manger pas forcément porteur
pour nous afin qu'ils sont bien placées
on va dire économique et on écoute leur
chef de file celui donc des sénateurs
des républicains bruno retailleau qui a
rencontré quand un câble mais le front
national c'est le parti du yaka fokon si
le parti de la démagogie franchement
est-ce que les français peuvent penser
qu'en abaissant l'âge de la retraite au
moment où on gagne chaque année 2 les
parents de l'espérance de vie
on va pouvoir régler le problème des
petites retraites ou des trous de
sécurité sociale certainement pas est-ce
que les français peuvent prendre penser
qu'en sortant de l'euro en sortant sans
doute du marché unique puisqu'on aurait
des droits de douane auxquels s'ajoutera
une contribution sociale en même temps
sur les importations
on pourra dynamiser l'emploi en france
certainement pas même les grecs mais
monsieur tsipras ce que monsieur
philippe au madame le pen avait salué
lors de son arrivée au pouvoir ont
renoncé au bord du gouffre parce que
évidemment si vous sortez demain dans
l'euro vous avez une explosion de la
dette
voilà guillaume neveu rejoint et vous
allez donc pouvoir répondre à la fois à
notre confrère de la fp et à bruno
retailleau convient d'entendre mon soir
florian philippot a donc à benoît
thériault s'appuyer sur le programme de
la fondation concorde
donc c'est un film tant que libéral qui
est assez proche des républicains
et selon ce film tant qu le le coût du
programme du front national ça serait
une augmentation de 120 milliards sur
cinq ans ça serait souvent cette
fondation une explosion du niveau des
dépenses publiques
je ne vous ai pas d'accord c'est une
fondation proche de l'ump donc elles
vous disent que le programme du front
national est mauvais le ca n'a rien
d'étonnant voilà tout cela n'est pas
objectif ni sérieux monsieur retailleau
donc un représentant des républicains
nous nous explique le programme du
français ferait exploser la dette par le
celui qui a fait exploser la dette
concrètement quand il était au pouvoir
c'est sarkozy plus 600 milliards d'euros
de dette publique en cinq ans pour
l'instant ça pas été battu c'est le
record la vème république y compris 84
nouveaux impôts et taxes créées sus car
si seulement là également un record sont
pas seulement la dette c'est la dépense
publique
nanti parler dit que la dépense publique
a continué d'augmenter sous sarkozy de
manière record donc géré ces gens là
sont des donneurs de leçons mais quelles
sont leurs résultats 0 catastrophique
alors où était le mal à l'aise vis dans
du pouvoir d'achat où était le président
qui devait ramener le chômage à 5 % en
2012 et il a fini à plus de 10% au moins
bon de la toussaint n'est pas personnel
sur les dépenses publiques du coup s'il
arrivait au pouvoir resterait quelques
frais de front national le front
national dit que déjà il n'acceptera pas
cette politique du marche ou crève
mais ce que peu c'est la politique du
marche ou crève c'est à dire c'est la
politique de l'austérité généralisée les
petits salaires les petites retraites
la privatisation générale des services
publics et et on continue dans cette
voie là mais je verrai on va vers une
société de la pauvreté générale mais que
et je savais pas quand même pour la
société pour la france le front national
augmenteraient les dépenses publiques où
le front national dit d'abord qu'on ne
se bat efficacement dans la
mondialisation que si on a des armes
qu'on a les mêmes armes que ses
adversaires mais à remettre son ni de
gauche ni de droite
elles sont efficaces ça s'appelle une
monnaie une politique monétaire c'est
quand même ce qu'on 95% des pays du
monde
ceux qui sont en dehors l'eau justement
c'est avoir des frontières face à la
concurrence déloyale des filtres et
c'est avoir une politique de patriotisme
économique
ça y est on le proposera déjà domaine
aux régionales en on souhaiterait que
dans les cantines scolaires dans les
cantines des lycées dans les entreprises
publiques
on achète prioritairement dans les
marchés publics français ou produits en
france
alors ça ce sont des armes que nous
n'avons pas et le conte nous n'avons
plus à cause d'eux après il ya qu à
l'union européenne et du psv nord après
il ya l'équilibré désarment ya les
rétorsions sous les 0 contre tous il n'y
a pas d' équilibre nous n'avons plus
d'armes
nous n'avons plus de possibilité de
défendre notre économie de la promouvoir
en france comme à l'international
et là on parle on peut peut-être parler
de me laisser très important parce que
tout le reste du clan ces gens là vous
dites vous parle d'un pot vous parle de
taxe vous parle de salaire de retraite
mais qu'en même temps il ne souhaite pas
modifier le modèle économique qui de
toute façon est générateur dessous
croissance de surendettement et
d'austérité et donc de surtaxation il
parle dans le vide
il est alors log ans de mandat au monde
des bons mots mais ils ne parlent pas
concrètement parlant concrètement il y
avait des mesures qui étaient dans le
programme du front national en 2012 par
exemple
le maintien de la retraite à 60 ans
est-ce que c'est toujours d'actualité
pour 2017 est ce que le front national
entend toujours i comme un comme un âge
légal
oui comme un nageur et j'avais le droit
sera retire à 60 ans rien ne vous
garantit que vous aurez 100% votre
retraite monsieur puisque nous avons
cette condition de 40 ans de cotisation
pour avoir les 100%
si vous partez plus tard et vous aurez
un bonus sur et si vous partez vers 60
ans mais vous n'avez pas vos 40 ans de
cotisations eh bien c'est votre choix
mais vous n'aurez pas votre prénom votre
retraite complète
d'accord oui parce que d'ailleurs
monsieur retailleau se trompe quand il
dit l'espérance de vie augmente tous les
ans et donc il faut augmenter l'âge de
départ à la retraite
il faut regarder les chiffres réellement
l'espérance de vie en 50 ans a gagné 15
ans en france mais l'espérance de vie
après 60 ans qui est la seule qui nous
intéresse pour le financement des
retraites n'a gagné que six ans d'accord
parce que le reste l'essentiel
s'explique par la chute heureux augmente
quand même un petit peu heureuse de la
mortalité infantile
voilà donc nous lui disons tant qu'on
n'a pas fait des économies qu'ils n'ont
pas fait
ces gens là le gaspillage dans les
collectivités territoriales et là il ya
des milliards à récupérer ça on va en
parler ap la fraude
non mais l'immigration la france de la
fraude mais on n'arrête pas de parler
des revenants fiscaux des revenus au
fisc
c'était ben oui elle est revenue qui
regarde oui c'est ça vient de milliards
par exemple les fantômes amicaux mais
non ne croyez pas non mais il faut le
faire bien sûr mais on va faire venir
chez sa mère demeure mais la fraude
c'est là que d'annoncer qu'on dit oui
mais il sait bien le faire à faire il
n'y a pas que cela
la fraude à la sécurité sociale la
fraude à la tva
la fraude j'ai rayé de la fraude la
fraude massive la fraude sociale en
france et c'est le travail au noir la
principale
le prince est la principale source va ya
du travail au noir oui et d'ailleurs
c'est le signe d'une société qui se
précarisent c1 à dax avant soirée des
comportements de patrons peut-être kiki
ceux qui ont recours au travail au noir
et kiki frau de l'état d'adp succès
quelque chose contre lequel c'est pas
bien de fraude et l'état il faut lutter
contre cela il faut donner le moyen à
ces petites entreprises quand elles
n'ont pas le choix si c'est une question
de choix et bien d' avant de pouvoir
embaucher de recruter légalement mais
pour ça il faut le rassurer les carnets
de commandes et une taxation juste et
non pas excessif comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui mais pour qu'on ait à mesure
dans le temps mais je dirais les
économies voilà parce que ces gens-là
donne des leçons à la terre entière
jeudi leurs résultats sont très mauvais
et ensuite ils n'ont pas fait les
économies qui s'imposait dans les
économies sur l'aide médicale d'état
qu'il fallait supprimer ils n'ont pas
fait l'ump sur l'immigration massive sur
le coup de l'asile la cour des comptes
et de 17,2 milliards par an c'est
considérable 2 milliard par an sur
l'union européenne ça on va on va parler
des économies que vous comptez voilà on
en reparlera mais ces dossiers sont des
milliards par an sur le programme de
2012 vous prenez le en gros de ne pas
revenir sur les lois sur les 35 heures
c'est aussi toujours d'actualité pour
l'instant le la le programme est très
simple c'est pas de loi générale parce
que déstabiliser re déstabiliser le
fonctionnement des entreprises notamment
des petites entreprises en pleine
période de crise ce serait pas réaliste
il peut y avoir des dérogations
s'il ya des accords ou désaccords locaux
des accords de branche
à condition par exemple si on repasse de
35 à 37 ou 39 par semaine histoire
objectif de revenir à 39
donc ce soit payée 30 secteurs donc se
soient payées 39 heures donc voilà très
bien long mais sinon c'est la société
encore une fois du marche ou crève c'est
à dire le programme commun eu le ps ump
donc on va parler des régionales pour
l'instant vous me m'arrêter si je dis
une bêtise n'y a pas de programme
national du front national pour les
régionales les sites internet fonctionne
pas encore il ya des bois ya des
déclarations des candidats donc est ce
qui aura un programme national du front
national des grands axes alors personne
je pense aucun parti n'a défini pour
l'instant le programme national
d'ailleurs je pense qu'un programme
national un programme n'aurait pas
beaucoup de sens pour les régionales
parce que les enjeux sont différents
il y aura des grands axes bien sûr il y
aura des grands axes sur les compétences
des régions qui sont les mêmes partout
les lycées la formation professionnelle
les transports régionaux enfin tout ce
que vous connaissez il y aura bien sûr
la lutte contre les gaspillages il ya
beaucoup à dire sur les dépenses
incroyablement inutile et désastreuse
des régions et on en trouve des exemples
navrant partout mais il y aura bien sûr
une déclinaison locale des enjeux locaux
des problématiques des projets locaux
qui seront détaillées région par région
ça sera les principales marges de
manoeuvre budgétaires du d'un président
de région front national les gaspillages
etc
vous pensez que vous pouvez oui il ya
plein axe et fiscales véritable ya très
peu de levier fiscal dans une région
c'est vrai donc de fait il faudra lutter
contre les gaspillages il faudra lutter
contre certaines dépenses inutiles ça
peut rapporter vraiment concrètement de
l'argent ça peut rapporter si on
rapporte au niveau national plusieurs
probablement plusieurs centaines de
millions d'euros oui d'accord mais si
vous voulez il ya aussi des questions
d'opportunité ce qu'on fait tel ou tel
projet est ce qu'on ne le fait pas et
puis dans les régions qui font qu'ils
vont qui sont en train de fusionner et
qui auront fusionné l'année prochaine il
faut gérer cette réforme territoriale et
or elle sera coûteuse et moi dans ma
région alsace champagne-ardennes
lorraine où je suis candidat je peux
vous dire qu'elle n'est pas apprécié
cette réforme tainio là parce qu'elle
n'a pas de sens et qu'elle va reléguer
des départements entiers la ruralité les
petites communes très loin de la
nouvelle est seul et unique capital qui
sera strasbourg qui est excentrée alors
c'est pas au milieu de la région ça ce
sera coûteux où ils n'ont même pas
réduit le nombre d'élus on aurait pu au
moins réduire le nombre d'élus alors que
nous proposions nous quand on sort et
fait des économies quand on suit votre
combat votre campagne aussi assidûment
qu'edvald ans aperçoit quand même que la
thématique de l'immigration revient en
force
vous confirmez avec ce mode de
submersion qui apparaît d'ailleurs sur
votre acte personnel et également dans
la bouche de marine le pen dans les
côtes
le problème c'est que nous sommes
confrontés submersion migratoire et que
ni l'ump ni le parti socialiste n'a pris
la mesure de ce qui est en train de se
passer et personne ne propose les
solutions fermes et évidente qui
permettront de nous protéger de cette
submersion migratoire
donc je vous avez vous avez fait je sais
pas c'est votre premier tract mais en
tout cas vous avez fait un tract sur la
submersion migratoire dans le cadre de
vos combats
de la campagne régionale marine le pen
parle de solutions évidentes je voulais
savoir au niveau des régions
concrètement que peut faire un plaisant
de réel sur la question des migrations
alors je vous réponds juste sur le trac
effectivement j'ai j'ai commencé une
petite tournée mais avant le lancement
d'ailleurs de la campagne qui sera
lancée dimanche de quelques villes qui
accueillent des migrants dans et
notamment des villes ump je suis allé à
thionville à epinal ce que ça me paraît
fort de café de d'accueillir des
migrants au moment où on a promis une
stabilisation fiscale et d'ailleurs qui
ont ville même moment augmente les
impôts seront une promesse de campagne
et accueille des migrants
ce qui n'est pas du tout ce que j'ai
ressenti sur le terrain en tout cas le
souhait des habitants de la ville
la région ne peut pas faire tout sur ce
sujet là est ce qu'elle peut faire au
moins quelques fois elle peut faire
quelque chose ça relève énormément du
national maintenant elle peut faire par
exemple arrêter d'engagés est ce que
toutes les régions quasiment sont en
train de voter c'est à dire des
subventions exceptionnelles pour les
migrants ça ça n'existera pas saouler
dans les régions front national c'est
des montants au niveau des budgets des
régions c'est pas des montants et je
crois que pas cassé 3 millions soit ne
trompe pas en lorraine 2 milliards le
budget de pâques a avancé ces noms mais
sur ce sont des mille écus télex
d'accord mais c'était un souhait est un
choix là et on ajoute des dépenses et
les dépenses et les dépenses et ça finit
par faire une grosse somme en lorraine
ils viennent de voter deux cent mille
euros
mais c'est une première avance qui vous
dit que l'année prochaine il
n'ajouterons pas un million
supplémentaire ou 2 millions
supplémentaires dans cette logique il
n'y a pas de patin là on n'y a pas de
alors que peut faire la région déjà ça
elle arrête ces subventions et lé
réattribue par exemple peuvent pas vers
nos petites entreprises locales qui
auraient besoin d'un petit d'un petit
coup de pouce pour se développer pour
embaucher un peu plus je crois que ce
serait nécessaire ou vers des projets
locaux 2 sa soeur est pas l'immigration
niveau de la région non mais ça déjà ça
s'arrête de l'attirer sahara est de
rendre la région de faire de la région
un centre d'accueil ramènerait que
quelques que la france paraît-il est
déserté par les réfugiés c'est ce qu'on
a pu constater un îlot froid non vous
vous seriez férié pour mêler le façon de
démentir l'idée que la france avec six
aides sociales soit un aspirateur là
la france chaque année l'un des
principaux pays d'asile du monde déjà
vous savez au japon japon ils sont deux
fois plus nombreux que nous et ils sont
riches aux affrontements
donc ils ont les moyens on est parmi les
derniers dans l'union européenne en
termes de rendre à bordeaux à la
polynésienne submergée par l'immigration
bon mais mais la france accueille
l'immigration massive
au japon ils ont eu cinq mille demandes
d'asile de l'an dernier ils ont accepté
11 est bon la france a deux êtres 65000
on en accepte un tiers donc ça fait plus
de vingt mille et est par ailleurs ceux
qui ne sont pas acceptés ne sera sera
déjà ils vont être à 800 milles mais ça
mais lui d'ailleurs à toute vitesse ils
remettent en place des frontières donc
on voit que c'est du grand n'importe
quoi
c'est de l'amateurisme ils sont
submergés eux aussi et d'ailleurs la
cour des comptes n'y a expliqué aussi
que les déboutés du droit d'asile sont
seulement 1% à être reconduits à la
frontière alors qu'il devrait être 100%
à être reconduits à la frontière
ils ne sont que 1 % et la région pourra
aussi arrêter de subventionner les
associations par exemple of key qui
défendent le communautarisme ou qui
soutiennent les clandestins alors la
zone ont le droit d'exister mais elles
n'ont pas l'aura d'être d'un autre sens
en tout cas d'être subventionné fin
l'armée un public vous faites quand même
la différence d'un mollah entre le
communautarisme et puis l'urgence
humanitaire dans les villes on en n'est
pas que dans l'urgence humanitaire peut
encore une fois encore mais je vous le
dis très clairement
s'il n'ya pas c'est l'immigration qui
arrivent en france n'est pas une
immigration d'urgence humanitaire c'est
faux c'est largement une immigration
économique qui arrive en france
et puis on peut imaginer au delà de nos
compétences et c'est quand même
intéressant et notamment si nous avons
si nous gagnons plusieurs régions mais
on le fera même dans une seule région et
leur région va en parler tout de suite
moi je lui ferais particulière